our dr david agus joins us now good
morning
and doctor none of the white house
recommendations are new so what are the
most
important changes schools should make to
safely reopen
thank you michelle you know it's
difficult
in that you know at the cdc you've got
the pros they're the best
you know epidemiologists in the world
and public health experts
and we're relying on local experts some
of whom are remarkable some of whom
aren't to make decisions and so you know
what schools have to do now is they have
to look in their area
what is the infection rate is it safe
for me to open or not and then what are
my
boundaries if something changes the
rates go up what do i do if they go down
what do i do
and then what's the behavior in the
school mandate wearing masks
social distancing arrangements of
classrooms who are the high-risk
teachers
who are the high-risk students there's a
lot of preparation that has to go in
all of this has to be done at the local
level because there weren't federal
guidelines on how to do this
and we're seeing a lot of these last
minute turnarounds you know dr
i thought i was sending a freshman off
to college this month i found out this
week
his school's going virtual i know you
have a college
age a student uh as both a doctor and a
father what would
what would you like to see
well you know what it's like you feel
horrible that your child is being
deprived of in-person learning right i
mean
you know the foundation of success is
education and we're changing education
as we speak
and so what i want is schools to be
transparent
here are how we're going to open and
when this happens we will do x or we
will do i there needs to be true
transparency
as a parent for you to be comfortable
with your child going to school
is when the levels hit this we're going
to actually
uh stop or we're going to quarantine
when somebody's positive and here's how
we're going to do it
we saw a high school recently that
quarantined 1200 people
after an infection after it was open so
real plans need to be made
and you know it worries me many schools
don't have contingency plans
they haven't established their
boundaries the federal guidelines now
are generic
know the symptoms of covid19 and that
you can act appropriately well that's
not a guideline
that's a suggestion well you believe we
need better federal
guidelines or guidance rather not a
state or local
issue keeping it at that level why is it
so important
because these are data driven and
every high school every college every
elementary school
needs to have the data to make the right
decisions
and they need to know exactly what to do
to keep safety we're talking safety of
children
of teachers and of parents because the
children's are going home
and they can hug mom and dad or grandma
or their next-door neighbor so it's not
just the children that we're focused on
so these guidelines matter this is the
future of our country or these children
and we have to figure out a way to
educate them safely and do the best we
have
best practices are critical we need to
start to establish what is the best
practice for an elementary school how do
we social distance
how do we get children to wear masks
what do we do when there's one case what
do we do when the number of cases go up
we need a book of guidelines for each of
these schools
on what to do and what i'm afraid now is
that really it is
local by local so you are trusting a
county or a local health official to
make a decision
in many cases they're going to do
exactly the right thing but in other
cases
they don't have the background or the
experience to do the right thing
well the president is saying he's ready
to deploy
the cdc teams to schools do you think
that would be effective
you know the cdc are remarkable
epidemiologists and public health
experts we cannot deploy them to every
school in the country
it's just not possible what we need them
to do is to make a playbook
and schools to follow that playbook if
you're in a remote area in your
university you can create a bubble just
like the nba did
and potentially educate your children's
if you're
a high school in an area where the
number of cases is going up dramatically
you may want to shut down a while to the
number of cases goes down else you're
going to have to quarantine a good
majority of the school
without a playbook i am really afraid of
what's going to happen
and that we're going to harm students
these are young kids we're going to harm
potentially parents
and teachers i i honestly am worried
doctor you've been on the ball about
this for a long time so
just we hope you're wrong about that dr
agus thank you so much
listen uh i hope i'm wrong too